téléphonie vous êtes en poste depuis un
peu plus d'un mois maintenant j'ai envie
de vous demander d'entrée de jeu comment
vous évaluer l'état de la relation entre
votre gouvernement et les première
nation québécoise
je vous dirais que encore beaucoup de
travail à faire c'est un nouvel élan
avec mon avant-postes de changer
certaines façons de faire et je donne un
exemple très concret ce que j'ai établi
avec les chefs et les grands chefs c'est
que nous devions faire des annonces
parce que les québécois demandent d'être
proactifs d'être dans l'action alors on
fait des annonces et j'ai déjà demandé
aux chefs et aux grands chefs on a
discuté
peut-être nous annonce ne seront pas à
100% selon vos attentes laisser une
chance et on prend les corrigés par la
suite à leur première grande annonce
qu'on a fait en matière de santé on sait
où on veut aller on sait que c'est la
sécurisation culturel on sait qu'il
travaille à faire là dedans
cependant le chemin à faire dans le
commun des treize ouvert à le travailler
avec les premières nations et jusqu'à
présent ça porte fruit pelé gens pressés
apprécieront sur l'injection mais qu'on
se laisse se peut cette flexibilité
l'aude en application vous parlez de
santé le conseil d éthique amic de
manouane il conseil de la nation
atikamekw ont déposé cette semaine
mémoire visant à faire valoir les droits
des autochtones au québec en matière de
santé on a parlé du principe de joyce
est ce que vous reconnaissez que les
québécois membres des premières nations
sont parfois traités de façon raciste
dans le système de santé
c'est évident qu'il ya du racisme c'est
d'évident qui est des gens qui sont
restés sont le déjà reconnue et c'est
pour ça qu'on s'y attaque et c'est pour
ça que notre première annonce
c'était vraiment en matière de santé
avec la sécurisation culturel oui à des
gens qui reçoivent pas le bon traitement
et c'est pour ça qu'on a décidé de
réagir
et d'annoncer des navigateurs des
navigateurs alphonse et des personnes
ressources qui vont dans tous les
établissements de santé pour accueillir
les membres des premières nations et
s'assurer qu'ils ont le bon traitement
comment comment concrètement ça se
traduit à quel moment vous vous dites
dans votre tête
il y en a plus de problème de traitement
entre les premières nations et les
personnels hospitaliers par exemple à
partir du moment qu'on voit on va
proposer au vote garantir un menhir je
pense que c'est un stage d'une grave
erreur
c'est un travail qui va prendre du temps
de l'énergie et je vous donne un exemple
quand on parle de formation oui une
formation initiale à faire mais ce
serait vraiment illusoire de dire que
par la suite c'est terminé c'est pas un
vaccin ont fait une première formation
après que les gens soient en poste
pendant quelques années
les revoir on refait une formation parce
que à ce moment là que je peux vous et
je les ai vécus dans mon ancienne vie
avec du bagage avec des connaissances
avec des exemples concrets
on est capables ensemble de trouver des
solutions à ces situations-là exemples
bien concrets pour travailler dans un
établissement de santé dans la région
joliette et lorsque les membres des
coordinations arrive pour les
traitements et arrivent en groupe en
groupe de 7,8 10 personnes on n'est pas
habitué à ça mais une fois qu'on le fait
qu on est capable de trouver des
solutions de et finalement c'est pas si
grave que ça c'est une réalité
c'est pour ça que ces points d'eau silva
se règle en quelques semaines ou
corrigera pas plus de sens et entendit
font en quelques semaines
faut il faire face pour mettre la bonne
énergie six coureurs ont parlé de
formation l'une des recommandations du
principe de joyce est entre autres
d'offrir une formation via l'ordre via
les ordres professionnels pour
sensibiliser le personnel hospitalier ce
que sera votre tête c'est une option
c'est quelque chose de réaliste je vous
dirais que dès notre première annonce
mon collègue christian dubé a pris une
décision que je trouve fort important
fort intéressante
on aurait pu décider justement que la
formation devait donner exemple aux
infirmières aux médecins aux préposés
aux bénéficiaires non sa diction 7 et 10
avec tout le personnel qui travaille
dans un établissement de santé et ça va
être obligatoire alors ce sont deux
décisions très importantes parce que
vous savez lorsque vous présentez vous
même à l'hôpital
la première personne vous allez
rencontrer ce n'est pas nécessairement
une infirmière c'est pour une semaine
propose aux vénitiens c'était quelqu'un
l'accueil c'est quelqu'un de la sécurité
quelqu'un de l'entretien on veut
s'assurer de former tout le monde des
établissements de soin mais moi je pense
que c'est une très bonne très bonne 10
yeux qui était prise vous avez parlé de
cette du travail qu'ils avaient à faire
pour rétablir les relations entre votre
gouvernement et les premières nations
vous avez annoncé cette semaine la
création d'une table politique conjointe
avec les premières nations
qu'est ce que ça vient faire
concrètement justement pour rétablir les
relations entre votre gouvernement et
les peuples autochtones au québec
vous savez j'ai cherché longtemps nos
termes que table politique souvent pour
les gens ça fait très très
technocratique ça fait peu dans l'action
puis une personne d'action c'est ce que
les gens nous demandent cependant je
pensais le bon tempo expliquer ce qu'on
va faire avec mon collègue le chef
jeulin picard je serais très heureux de
regarder des enjeux qui sont plus large
alors ça ne remplace en rien les
relations que j'ai avec les différentes
nations avec les différentes communautés
auxquelles ces exemples cette semaine
j'étais en début de semaine dans la
région de val-d'or pour régler un enjeu
important
les négociations d'un au sujet de la
chasse à l'orignal
j'ai eu des rencontres jusqu'à vendredi
avec la nation islamique
alors cette table ne remplace pas nos
négociations qu'on est au quotidien
cependant lorsqu'on regarde des enjeux
beaucoup plus large au niveau
territorial au niveau de suivi justement
des recommandations de la commission vie
on peut les faire ensemble et de
prioriser quelles sont les attentes des
différentes nations de 55 communauté ou
québec alors quelles sont les priorités
qu'ils ont été bien ensemble est ce que
très intéressant dans ce que dans notre
engagement avec la pnq elle c'est de
venir dire que cet envoi rendre compte
au premier ministre directement alors
vraiment c'est ce qu'un 4 on parle d'une
relation de nation à nation est un bel
exemple
monsieur la première je vous écoute il
n'y a pas de gouvernement j'ai pas
entendu le gouvernement dans le passé me
dire on est contre l'idée d'entretenir
des relations qui est le pactole c'est
toujours un peu le même discours que
l'on entend
et pourtant on a l'impression qu'au fil
du temps ça n'avance pas pourquoi ça
avancerait davantage avec vous savez ça
va être difficile de faire une première
pige depuis je fais ce métier ça fait
juste deux ans j'ai jamais voulu faire
deux premiers je détestais les promesses
j'ai promis une chose c'est d'être
honnête est intègre
est ce que je pourrais manque
aujourd'hui quand je rencontre les chefs
et les grands cherchent leur écoute et
la promesse que je vous fais les traire
on est avec vous d'être transparent et
de reconnaître que beaucoup de travail à
faire et vous savez je demande aux gens
de me juger sur les actions et jusqu'à
présent on est rendu à trois semaines
depuis mon annonce de ces actions long
de trois semaines d'annonce très concret
on avance est-ce que tout va être réglé
dans quelques semaines quelques mois la
réponse est non ce que c'est un
processus qui va prendre des mois des
années
oui absolument il faut mettre l'énergie
là dedans moi ce que je vous dis c'est
qu'on est dans l'action des cons quand
on sera jugé dans nos actions mais il
faut avancer il faut changer la façon de
des tables et nos relations
en passant le chemin votre seul puis
j'ai déjà dans mes rencontres avec
toutes les nations j'ai déjà dit qu'il y
aurait des monts
après disent ils il faut être prêt on a
un très transparent et plus les moments
difficiles plus on va voir communiquer
et s'expliquer ce que pour bien
fonctionner l'exemple du pas levé andré
a été difficile moi je suis heureux de
voir qu'on ait pu commencer des
négociations mais c'est sûr que beaucoup
de travail puis c'est ce qui va re des
embûches
ian lafrenière ministre des affaires
autochtones du québec merci infiniment
merci à vous